Peter Kornblum director of the National
Security Archives Chile documentation
project led a campaign to declassify
documents regarding the US government's
relationship with the Pinochet
dictatorship and Chile next on book TV
he details his findings it's an hour and
15 minutes last Thursday was the 30th
anniversary of the 1973 coup in Chile
and we're very honored to have mr. Peter
Korn blue here his new book is called
the Pinochet file
Peter Korn blue is director of the
National Security Archive a library of
declassified US government material
based in George Washington University
and she's written several books based on
documents that have been released by the
US government on iran-contra the Bay of
Pigs the Cuban Missile Crisis this is a
very important book it's a very
interesting book leads one to the
impression that well it's a very
controversial book as well but one of
the things that has always been argued
by those conservatives in Chile was that
the coup was in it something that
happened from the inside but what this
book clearly shows is that there was an
awful lot of stuff going on from the
outside and ladies and generally to
welcome mr. Peter corn blue
thank you so much it's a so nice to be
here it's so nice to see so many
familiar faces people I worked with for
many many years you know and I know and
I think you know that a large community
has been built around the issue of Chile
many people including some who are here
today came directly from Chile after the
coup and started organizations here in
Washington to work towards human rights
and the restoration of democracy there
that in some ways changed the history of
our country certainly changed our laws
and I think had a great impact on on
people like like myself and it was
always a great satisfaction for me
knowing that in writing this book I
might make a small contribution to that
to the work of that community and and
and take my place in it I want to start
with a Declassified document but but of
course a Declassified document this is a
book of built around declassified
documents let me just tell you what it
is this is a memorandum that Henry
Kissinger's deputy at the National
Security Council a man named Byron Vicki
wrote to him on September 14th 1970
September 14th was 11 days after
socialist leader Salvador Allende was
elected democratically to the presidency
of Chile
he hadn't been inaugurated yet and
wasn't due to be inaugurated for another
six weeks but he had been elected 11
days earlier and already the White House
was considering what kind of covert
actions might be implemented to keep him
from actually assuming the presidency
and this is what
Kissinger's deputy wrote to him opposing
US covert operations to thwart a yen day
from becoming president what we proposed
vicki wrote is patently a violation of
our own principles and policy tenants
this is a secret sensitive memo by the
way
moralism aside this has practical
operational consequences if these
principles have any meaning we normally
depart from them only to meet the
gravest threat to us example given to
our survival is I end a a mortal threat
to the United States baekje posed this
question to kissinger and he answered it
it is hard to argue this these words I
think resonate today as we discuss
whether in today's world we face mortal
threats abroad and what the appropriate
US response should be Chile also
resonates as an example an original
example a rather classic example of a
preemptive strike think about it the day
after this memo was written Kissinger
ignoring this advice went to a 15-minute
meeting in the Oval Office with Richard
Nixon on September 15th CIA director
Richard Helms was there and we have
Richard Helms as handwritten notes from
this meeting the orders of the President
of the United States this is a rather
famous document I don't know how many of
you have seen this document before very
very few of you only only a small
handful this document has actually been
around for almost 27 years
it was Declassified during the special
Senate investigation into Chile in 1975
this is an important document this is
the only extant document the only
Declassified document we have of the
President of the United States of
America ordering the overthrow of a
democratically elected government
certainly we have declassified documents
going way back of presidents ordering
the overthrow of of other regimes not
elected ones ones that came to power
through armed force such as Fidel
Castro's etc but this is the only one we
have of a president ordering the
rollback of a decision by another
country to democratically like their
leader
and this document reads one in ten
chance perhaps would save Chile worth
spending ten million dollars available
more if necessary no involvement of the
embassy don't tell the Ambassador this
is a full-time job best men we have give
me a game plan and then the most famous
line make the economy scream I'm going
to pass this document around just
because I want people to be able to see
it for themselves
this was Richard Nixon saying to the CIA
I want you to foment chaos in Chile make
the economy scream do what is necessary
to create a situation whereby the
military moves to block I na from
actually being inaugurated president of
Chile now think about it preemptive
strike this document is dated September
15th 1970 again day is not due to be
inaugurated for another six weeks until
November 3rd 1970 he is not yet assume
the presidency he has yet to implement
as president of Chile a single a single
policy detrimental to US interests and
yet Nixon had decided as CIA director
Helms told his staff the next day that I
and a was and I quote unacceptable to
the United States and had ordered the
CIA to foment this coup the country of
Chile
the Chilean poet Pablo Neruda once
described his country as a long pedal of
sea wine and snow how many of you have
ever been there well good good many of
you and you know you know that this is a
beautiful beautiful country it starts
with an extremely dry desert in the
north and it ends with glaciers in the
south and in between there are lots and
lots of vineyards and grapes that turn
in a wonderful Chilean wine and copper
mines and the songs of Victor Jara and
eating lomani floating in the air it's a
it's a beautiful beautiful country in
Neruda obviously kept captured what a
what an extraordinary place it was now
Kissinger Henry Kissinger once described
Chile as quote a dagger pointed at the
heart of Antarctica what did he mean he
meant that of course Chile was a country
dangerous to nothing it was a weapon
pointed at nowhere it had no strategic
importance to the United States but I'm
here to tell you tonight that that was
before I end his election on September
4th 1970 he uttered those words in 1969
in a conversation with Chile's foreign
minister who was trying to get him to
pay more attention to the Southern Cone
and his response was well your country
is a dagger pointed at the heart of
Antarctica really not so much worth my
time when it became apparent to dr.
Kissinger in the fall in the summer of
1970 given the polling in Chile that INE
might actually win in a three-way race
he ordered the intelligence community
State Department's Bureau of
intelligence and research the CIA's
western hemisphere desk the Defense
Intelligence Agency to all do an
assessment what would be the impact of
ien day's election on the United States
this was a
threat assessment type of thing that all
the agencies were doing about Iraq over
the last two years or so and the
intelligence community did a
full-fledged national security study
memorandum and they came back with a
following conclusion one a yen days
election would not change the balance of
military power the balance of power in
the world Chile under IND would pose no
strategic threat to US interests the
only impact of Ayana selection would be
a psychological impact on other
countries in Latin America which might
want to follow Chile's lead and move
peacefully through the democratic
process to elect reformers and and
political figures who would Institute
through the democratic process
substantive change that would affect US
economic interests obviously in US
diplomatic interests that was the
assessment of the intelligence community
that is not what however Henry Kissinger
told Richard Nixon first under Nixon's
orders of September 15th the United
States tried to foment a coup covertly a
very small group of CIA officials trying
to find a Chilean military clique that
would move against a yen day that effort
that operation led to the assassination
of the Chilean commander-in-chief
general Rene Schneider on October 22nd
1917 Eider was the equivalent of the
head of our Joint Chiefs of Staff
he was a constitutionalist he opposed a
coup none of the military under him
would move without his orders and so the
CIA and the three or four Chilean
generals they were working with came up
with this 17 point plan which I've
actually copied and put in the book that
would start with general Schneider's
kidnapping he would be kidnapped he'd be
secretly flown to Argentina a coup
plotter would replace him as
commander-in-chief they'd the military
would declare that I yin days supporters
had been responsible for this kidney
Epping they would declare martial law
sweep through all of the shanty towns
where ene supporters lived rest people
kind of decapitate the opposition annul
the elections and then and then the plan
kind of stopped there there was no call
for return of democracy there was no
scheduling of new elections etc that
plan is in the book at the bottom of
that plan by the way is the request to
the CIA for $50,000 to pay the group
that was going to undertake this this
kidnapping
instead of kidnapping Schneider he was
shot and killed the CIA headquarters in
Langley sent a cable which I've also
reproduced in the book the next day
basically commending the station in
Santiago for an excellent job that's a
quote an excellent job in bringing
Chileans to the point where a military
solution is possible for them of course
anybody who observed Chile anybody who
knew anything about Chile's strong
tradition of democracy and the lack of
any political violence in the recent
memory in that country would understand
that a shooting of this kind would rally
the Chilean people around there around
their leaders this was an act of
terrorism in Chile that was tantamount
to to to an act of terrorism here in
Washington - it really was the
equivalent for Chileans at that point of
the Kennedy assassination here for us it
was it was a shock a shock to the system
and of course the Chilean Congress
two days later ratified a yen day
overwhelmingly and he became president
on November 3rd Kissinger 48 hours later
November 5th
brings a rather comprehensive set of
briefing papers using these are them to
Richard Nixon and he says to Nixon
tomorrow you're going to hold a National
Security Council meeting and it is
absolutely imperative that you lay down
the law to everybody in the National
Security of bureaucracy in the State
Department and Defense Department the
CIA that you want a yen date opposed as
strongly as possible if you don't do
this Kissinger
argued there will be a drift towards a
modus vivendi with the IND government
because the State Department is believes
that there's nothing we can do except
live without yen day and hope that he
becomes unpopular and is voted out 1976
I oppose that Kissinger wrote he wrote
to Richard Nixon this is this is rather
extraordinary he wrote to Richard Nixon
a yen date will seek to quote be
internationally respectable move
cautiously and pragmatically avoid
immediate confrontation with us move
slowly in formalizing relations with
Cuba and other socialist countries these
are all the things that he said that he
said I yen day would do it doesn't seem
so outrageous does it but for Kissinger
this was a yen days game plan this was a
way for him to somehow lull the United
States into thinking that they could get
along with him and for Kissinger he laid
out a series of issues that was a threat
to the United States in fact he said to
Nixon the main problem with a yen day is
that he is going to set an example the
example of a successfully elected
Marxist government in Chile would have
an impact on an even President value for
other parts of the world especially
Italy especially countries in Western
Europe and the initiative spread of a
similar of similar phenomena elsewhere
would in turn have a significant effect
on the world balance in our own position
in it and this is Kissinger now goading
Richard Nixon it's it's amazing to
listen the way they discussed these
issues together the election of Ind
Kissinger says to to Richard Nixon poses
one of the most serious challenges ever
faced in this hemisphere and your
decision as to what to do may be the
most historic and difficult foreign
policy decision you will have to make
this year and it goes on to argue all
the reasons why the Richard Nixon must
lay down the law
and that is what that is what Nixon did
I'm going to pass around the meeting the
next day of Nixon and his National
Security Council aides the Vice
President the Secretary of State
Secretary of Defense I just want you to
be able to see what what I've been able
to see it which is the way that that our
highest US officials discussed together
in a conference room the future of
another country regime change
that's really what it was this was an
explicit discussion about regime change
in Chile you have the Secretary of
Defense Melvin Laird saying we have to
hurt ie end a and bring him down and you
have the Secretary of State saying yes I
agree with that we have to hurt him and
bring him down but we have to do it in a
way that the rest of the world doesn't
see what we're doing because obviously I
en DS legitimate leader of Chile he's
democratically elected we've repeatedly
stated that we respect international
sovereignty of other countries and
Democratic will of other citizenry's so
we can't openly do this we have to have
a hostile approach but but disguise it
as a finesse it as a as essentially a
cool and distant approach rather than
rather than of US aggression let me just
send this around to you is one of the
most extraordinary documents that that
was Declassified in the last several
years
let me talk about the documents as I
just inferred the value of these
documents is extraordinary you and I can
be a fly on the wall as the highest US
officials discussed and deliberated
strategies for for u.s. foreign policy
in this case for for bringing down
another government for determining the
future of another country we can be in
the room when decisions are discussed
when objections are raised when orders
are given and it really these documents
really let you understand the mindset of
our highest leaders and the President
appears in many of these documents
Kissinger appears in many of these
documents his aides present him with
counter arguments and many of these
documents you understand the way foreign
policy makers think about other
countries the way they have a sense of
their own power and the implementation
of that power in other countries and you
certainly get a sense a very detailed
sense of the actions taken this one it
describes you very briefly how we got
these documents and how I was able to
use a whole new jet a whole new set of
Declassified records to try and
reappropriation Archaea was arrested in
London this was a stunning event it
shocked the world it delighted many many
people who had been waiting a long long
time for this to happen and never
believed it would frankly there was a
small group particularly of Spanish
lawyers one of them a former Spanish
aide to Salvador Allende
who had spent 25 years after the coup
trying to work on human rights in Chile
trying to adjust and rewrite the laws in
Spain to make Spanish law applicable to
pinochet's crimes and had eventually
succeeded in doing this so Spain as you
may recall had petitioned London for
Pinochet's extradition he was
vacationing in London he had hurt his
back I decided to have back surgery it
was laid up in a private clinic the
London clinic when Spain through
Interpol served an arrest warrant on him
this created a huge outcry around the
world an effort around the world to
present the evidence of Pinochet's
crimes in the United States where
Pinochet secret police had committed an
egregious act of international terrorism
the September 1976 bombing car bombing
of Orlando Letelier is car and killing
him
in today's leading critic in the United
States former Chilean ambassador here in
his American colleague Ronnie carp and
Moffett on September 21st 1976 right
down there and shared encircle sure many
of you have seen the small monument that
is there but Pinochet in other words had
committed a crime here and there was a
pressure here on the Clinton
administration if Spain was going to ask
for Pinochet's extradition why the
United States asked for Pino che's
extradition on the grounds of
prosecuting this act of international
terrorism and the families of Pino
chaise American victims the families of
Ronnie carp and Moffett the families of
Orlando Letelier those are that were
living here and as well as Isabel his
widow who was living in Chile at the
time pressed very hard for for that case
to be reopened
Joyce hormann the widow of Charles
Horman the American killed after the
coup also lent her voice very loudly to
pressuring the Clinton administration to
help with the prosecution of Pinochet in
Spain for a variety of reasons the clean
ministration did not want to add to the
concept of universal jurisdiction
there's a fear in this country that
American
officials will someday come under the
globalization of justice and that the
Pinochet president the Pinochet
president is not particularly good for
officials like Henry Kissinger perhaps
others and so the United States is not
very fond of supporting that concept and
so the administration decided not to
directly help the Spanish with evidence
but we in my office and and and many
others worked with the administration
kind of from the outside through through
political pressure from Congress through
through through newspaper articles media
coverage and from the inside through the
context that we had with with very very
strong courageous officials inside the
Clinton ministration to say look if you
don't do something here if you don't
make some kind of gesture in this case
you're simply going to be protecting one
of the vilest dictators in the recent
history of South America of Latin
America why don't you just declassify
all the holdings on the Pinochet era why
don't you just declassify the CIA
reports on Pinochet atrocities the CIA
and Defense Intelligence Agency reports
on Pino chase terrorism inside chilly
outside Chile etc and eventually the
administration decided to do a major
declassification project not just on the
17 years of the Pinochet dictatorship
but actually even back to us holdings on
on the I yen date period this was an
idea of some some conservative in the in
the State Department who said well if we
declassified documents on Pinochet we
have to declassify documents Allende
because he was a socialist and he did
bad things and we don't want to seem
imbalanced against Pinochet we need to
declassify documents on an IND also well
I could only stand back and applaud this
this decision because in so doing this
particular individual opened the door to
forcing the CIA to declassify documents
on its involvement in political violence
and terrorism in Chile in other words
all the covert operations that took
place between 1970 and 1973 to undermine
the I end a government
twenty-four thousand documents were
Declassified over two-year period 24,000
secret documents that we hadn't seen
before and they told an extraordinary
story of US policy starting in 1970
before I end a selection and ending in
1990 with Pinochet being voted out of
office in a plebiscite and actually
turning over power to two civilians at
least partially turning over power to a
civilian government and the documents
you know there were quite a few of them
24,000 and if you even if you put them
in order and if you divide them up day
by day you almost had coverage of almost
every day of that 20-year period or
certainly the most critical days of that
20-year period and it allowed us to go
back and revisit this history it allowed
me to take a stab at rewriting this
history both the history of US efforts
to undermine Salvador Allende undermine
democracy and Chile and the history of
us efforts to bolster Augusto Pinochet
particularly in the first three years
after his coup we've just passed the
30th anniversary of the coup in Chile a
lot of focus was on that three-year
period 72 73 and what the United States
did I'll leave it to you to examine the
first two chapters of the book and the
25 or 30 documents that go with the
first two chapters of the book to have a
sense of what new we've been able to
learn I wanted to spend just a minute
with you though talking about the post
coup period which we're in right now
what was going on 30 years ago today on
September 16th and I can tell you from
the declassified documents what was
going on secret back channel efforts to
send messages to Augusto Pinochet that
the
United States government would avidly
support him a whole series of meetings
in Washington cable traffic down to
Santiago secret in new media is going to
augusto pinochet starting on the 13th of
September 48 hours after the coup and
going all the way through in the weeks
to come let me just share with you the
first cable that went down to Santiago
to the to the embassy giving them
instructions on what to tell what to
tell Augusto Pinochet we had Henry
Kissinger who was up on Capitol Hill at
this very same time fortuitously
coincidentally he was being confirmed as
Secretary of State the day after the
coup and his confirmation hearings were
being held and of course he was peppered
with questions about the u.s. role in
the coup and what the u.s. policy was
towards the new military junta and he
said to them we are neutral towards this
change of government so we didn't want
to make the mistake that we made in 1964
when we ran out and embraced the
military regime that took power in
Brazil at that time we learned our
lesson then we're remaining neutral now
at the very time he was saying that to
the Senators top secret cables were
being sent to the US Embassy in in
Santiago Chile to pass a message to
Augusto Pinochet and this cable is
titled US government attitude toward
Hunta the US government wishes to make
clear its desire to cooperate with the
military Hunta and to assist in any
appropriate way we agree that it is best
initially to avoid too much public
identification between us and so we are
pleased to maintain unofficial contacts
only three or four days later a similar
cable went down we want the government
of chile to know of our strongest desire
to cooperate closely in a
- firm basis for cordial and most
constructive relationship the documents
allow you to see behind the scenes what
was going on and these cables are being
sent at all mostly identical these
cables are going down to Chile at the
identical time that CIA intelligence
reports are coming up from Chile on
massive bloodshed massive bloodletting
by the Chilean military the CIA
even though engaged in specific covert
operations one wing of the station
they're routinely reported on various
aspects of repression as did the Defense
Intelligence Agency in Santiago so you
have literally dozens and dozens of
reports on impression starting from the
day a following the coup and going all
the way up through to the late 1980s the
bloodshed was so widespread in the days
following the coup that that the CI
sources really couldn't even accurately
count how many people had been killed by
the military one week after the coup a
cable came up saying that 4,000
civilians had been killed in the
aftermath of the coup another cable came
up a few days later saying that a source
had said from anywhere from 2,000 to
10,000 civilian casualties had taken
place because of the coup and after the
coup a few weeks later the CIA
intercepted a secret report that had
been written by chilean military for the
hunter to report on the exact figures
how many people were killed in the three
weeks after the coup how many people
have been arrested how many people have
been detained where they were being
detained etc and in the three weeks
following the coup according to this
intelligence report about 12 to 13
hundred civilians had been killed 350 to
400 of them summarily executed 13700
have been rounded up taken to the
National Stadium in Chile and they're
several hundred were actually executed
among them
two American citizens Charles Horman and
Frank Teru gee we can chart our
policymakers response to to this
information we know when Kissinger
received reports of these atrocities one
of the most extraordinary documents was
a Declassified transcript of a Kissinger
staff State Department staff meeting on
October 1st when his assistant secretary
for Latin America comes in right from
Capitol Capitol Hill and he says you
know the senators have been saying to me
you know what about these massacres what
about all these deaths and and assistant
secretary says the Kissinger can it be
true what what should I tell which I
tell the senators and Kissinger says
point-blank to his staff I want us to
understand our policy however bad the
behavior of this new military government
it is better for us and for our
interests than I yen day was that was
the policy that was that was laid down
to to you to US officials Kissinger
really had a disdain for the issue of
human rights he believed that human
rights got in the way of diplomacy and
power politics
he was a man who believed in realpolitik
at one point when the US ambassador sent
up a cable had talked about human rights
atrocities in Chile he scrawled on it
cut out the political science lectures
the Declassified transcripts of his
meetings are rather extraordinary they
reveal attitudes that that are even you
know even hard for for someone as jaded
as myself who has studied dr.
Kissinger's policies in Chile to to
believe as the repression got worse in
Chile over the first couple of years
Kissinger came under increased pressure
from beneath from his own staff to bring
up the issue to press the issue of human
rights with the Chilean regime he really
didn't want to do this and he seemed to
be more critical of the people in his
own State Department raising the issue
then of the Chileans themselves and I'll
just
I'll just give you an example this is a
memorandum of conversation between
Kissinger and and P no J's Foreign
Minister in September of 1975 foreign
minister Petruchio Carvajal and the
Foreign Minister comes into this meeting
and in all these meetings there would be
a note taker would take shorthand and
then the shorthand would be transcribed
and you'd actually have a full
transcript of everything that was said
which fortunately exists today and those
of you who worked on human rights in the
mid-1970s in Chile will appreciate this
the Foreign Minister comes into this
meeting and and the first thing he says
to Kissinger is I want to thank you for
giving us this opportunity to talk to
you and Kissinger says to him well I
read the briefing paper for this meeting
and it was nothing but human rights the
State Department is made up of people
who have a vocation for the ministry
because there are not enough churches
for them they went into the Department
of State and that that was the attitude
that that he professed we we have we
have another transcript which is which
is equally extraordinary and that is a
transcript of Henry Kissinger's private
discussions with Augusto Pinochet in
Chile in June of 1976 Pino chase staff
had pressed him to say something about
human rights to go to the OAS conference
in Chile and make a speech about human
rights and they touted this to the US
Congress and the American public has a
change of US policy the United States
was going to pressure the Chilean
government on human rights and in his
memoirs the third volume of his memoirs
Kissinger writes about this meeting with
Pino Cheney says you know I went in
there and I talked to General Pinochet
about democracy and human rights and I
told him he had to clean up his act or
or US aid was going to get cut off I
pressed him on this issue
Pinochet complained Kissinger writes
that that his friends the United States
was treating him badly and I returned to
my theme of democracy and human rights
that is what Kissinger
in his in his memoir we got the
Declassified transcript of this actual
meeting which is amazing that it
survived and that we now have it to
compare to what dr. Kissinger writes in
his memoirs and what he does in this
meeting is he goes in and talks to
Pinochet and basically says look this is
what I'm going to say and this is why I
have to say it and I want you to
understand this and this is actually
what he says he reviews with Pinochet
what he is going to say in the speech
he's about to give the speech two weeks
later and he says I will call attention
to to Human Rights I can do no less
without producing a reaction in the
United States which might lead to
legislative restrictions on aid military
and economic aid with you the speech is
not aimed at Chile he says to Pinochet I
wanted to tell you about this my
evaluation is that you are a victim of
all left-wing groups around the world
and that your greatest sin was that you
overthrew a government which was going
communist just a few minutes later in
the meeting he is talking to Pinochet
and Pinochet is complaining as Kissinger
wrote in his memoirs that the United
States is treating him badly the United
States treats its friends badly and
Kissinger writes in his memoirs as I
just said that I returned to my theme of
human rights and democracy in fact when
you read the transcript you see that he
did not return to this theme Pinochet
complains you have a punitive system for
your friends and Kissinger responds
there is merit in what you say it is a
curious time in the United States it is
unfortunate we have been through Vietnam
and Watergate we have to wait until the
elections the election the 1976 election
between Ford and Carter we welcomed the
overthrow of the communist inclined
government here we are not out to weaken
your position at the very end of the
meeting
Kissinger says we want to help not
undermine you you did a great service to
the West in overthrowing a yen day this
is the type of history that the
documents gives us and it enables us to
return to the issues of the past to
re-examine them to understand how
they're relevant to today many of the
issues that were debated around Chile
issue of US intervention the issue of
regime change the issue of a preemptive
strike the issue of honesty and
dishonesty in government is to issue of
covert operations and controls over them
the issues of what was being done in the
name of the American people around the
world in their name but without their
knowledge all those issues came to play
in Chile when you study Chile there's an
echo obviously in the present that's
worth considering but on its own it is
worth evaluating as a case study of
morality and immorality in the exercise
of US foreign policy it continues to
plague US foreign policy makers right on
the eve of the war in Iraq a questioner
stood up and asked Secretary of State
Colin Powell how the United States could
argue on moral grounds that we should go
in and overthrow Saddam Hussein given
what we had done in Chile overthrowing
ie na and supporting Pinochet and Paul's
response was Chile in the 1970s it is
not a part of our country's history that
we are proud of I'll stop there I will
take any questions that you have and
thank you again for for coming
can we have people line up here and ask
you questions to the microphone here
would that be okay can you announce that
there that's fine I don't know if that
mic is working too loud I'm willing
anybody can line up there people want to
shout out their questions so everybody
can hear you can do that too you need
people to be at the microphone it's a
few repeats of questionnaire they would
like people to go to the microphone and
ask the questions in this first case I
will I will repeat the question which
was do I do I think that Kissinger is
indictable for Orlando Letelier and
Ronnie Moffat you know I think the
answer to that is no there's a
fascinating story of what the US
government Kissinger's office in the CIA
knew about chilean plans to assassinate
critics abroad prior to the Letelier
Moffet assassination and it's a story
that is told in the book all the
documents telling what prior knowledge
the US government had about this
consortium of secret police agencies in
the southern cone called called
Operation Condor that was the the
mechanism under which assassins
terrorists came to Washington and
planted this bomb is rather amazing for
more than 25 years we only had one
Declassified document on
Operation Condor and the Letelier
assassination and it was an FBI report
dated a week after the assassination and
it appeared to be an
it appeared to be an intelligence report
it was an FBI intelligence report based
on intelligence get gained from
Argentina and it said that it is likely
that the assassination in Washington was
a phase three operation of Operation
Condor and for 25 years we thought given
this document that the US government
officials had learned a week after the
fact about Operation Condor and then
when all the documents were Declassified
several years ago we found out that in
fact the CIA had known five months
before the Letelier Moffet assassination
about Condor and it's assassination
plans excuse me not the specific
Letelier mission but the fact that these
governments and the Secret Service's
secret police agencies of these
governments had met together and had
designed a plan to to coordinate
surveillance on their critics around the
world and to send special teams out to
kill specific critics in Europe in Latin
America and in the United States in the
book I have the Intelligent that was
given to Kissinger on August 3rd 1976
about this intelligence and what to do
about it and it turns out that this was
a case in some ways it resonates so
forcefully with our own September 11
2001 this is a case where there was
abundance an abundance of intelligence
that could have been put together in one
place and some response issued that
would have detected and deterred this
mission and for a variety of reasons
that was not that was not done the most
ironic extraordinary document is a
document dated September 20th 1976 in
the late afternoon from the assistant
secretary for Latin America saying let's
close down all efforts to say to the
Condor countries that we oppose what
they're doing because there doesn't seem
to be any active assassination plans
afoot 18 hours later the bomb went off
at Sheridan Circle in Washington
we have a line of people I'll keep my
answer shorter
what role did investor Nathaniel Davis
who was in Santiago at the time play in
all this Nathaniel Davis was our
ambassador starting in 1972 in Chile he
left in the fall of 73 after the coup he
was there in the final months of Ind and
was there in the initial weeks of the
the Pinochet regime he played an
interesting role he opposed certain
plans that the CIA had to to directly
sponsor protests and agitation and
strikes in the street he sided with
another State Department official back
here in Washington in suggesting that
the CIA not be so aggressive because for
him it wasn't clear that the Chilean
military was actually ready to foment a
coup and he was concerned that the
United States would be directly
implemented in a failed coup or etc and
he just didn't feel that that was given
that you see I had already participated
in a failed coup 3 years earlier in the
fall of 1970 he he actually opposed that
he however was very aggressive in trying
to promote the Hunta from the moment
that it that it took office he sent back
a series of cables some of which are
reproduced in the book suggesting aid to
the hanta he personally came up with the
idea of sent of the CIA secretly
sponsoring a tour around the world of
members of the Chilean Christian
Democratic Party to present a
justification for the coup to Europe and
the rest of Latin America and
diplomatically and politically and
economically
he pressed very quickly for aid to be
given to to Pinochet there is a document
in the book where he of a conversation
he has with Pinochet as he's getting
ready to leave Santiago and return to
Washington which is which is quite
interesting actually what has been the
consequence of the doctrine of universal
jurisdiction issue
by the Spanish judge first of all what
happened to Pinochet was he ever tried
and you know adjudicated and has it ever
been a precedent has it ever happened
again it is a precedent and I think it
has had a very significant impact
specifically to Pinochet Pinochet spent
a year under house arrest in London more
than a year aback by the the British
courts ruled repeatedly that legally he
should be extradited to Spain to stand
trial
behind the scenes deal was cut between
the British government and the Chilean
government which didn't want Pinochet
sent to to Spain they preferred that
nothing happened to him but since this
had been a very embarrassing episode
they argued that they would prosecute
him in Chile and that would be the best
thing for Chilean nationalism and for
the Chilean legal system if he was
prosecuted there so he was sent back to
Chile at that point I think all
observers of his case thought that this
was over but in fact a very aggressive
and courageous judge judge Guzman in
Santiago pressed forward with charges
against Pinochet he was actually
indicted there he was stripped of his
political immunity and at one point he
came about this close to having his
mugshot taken and being fingerprinted
eventually after a whole round of court
votes all the way up to the Supreme
Court the Court ruled that for the same
given reason that he had been allowed to
leave London that he could not be tried
in Chile and that was mental incapacity
mental dementia at that point that
ruling he was about 85 86 years old he
immediately after this ruling wrote a
letter which was quite coherent for
somebody who was mentally demented
announcing that he was going to withdraw
from public life and that he hoped
Chileans would understand the great
effort he had made on their behalf
during during his time in government but
the impact of that case certainly
has led other countries to press for
similar types of cases around the world
and I think it has empowered the
International Court of Justice where
Milosevic is being tried right now
there's a case that's going to be taking
place right here in the United States in
Florida starting on Monday the Chilean
family who's whose brother was killed in
what was called a caravan of death which
I described in the book which was a kind
of a death squad that Pinochet sent out
after the coup to fly into other
provinces of the country and take people
who were had been put in prison i n days
civic leaders to share us the mayors the
police chiefs etc they'd all been
imprisoned after the coup but he sent in
a helicopter squad and everywhere the
helicopter landed at night these
political prisoners would be taken out
of the prison and and March to a ravine
and shot and a number of them had been
disappeared and one of them was the
brother of Zita caballo who lives in San
Francisco and one of the members of this
squad that was on this helicopter came
the United States it was part of the
Letelier mission to kill Orlando
Letelier he eventually turned himself in
US authorities served I don't know
something on the order of 11 months in
jail he'd cut a plea bargain with the
Justice Department which seems to have
included not sending him back to Chile
and they are bringing a lawsuit against
him actually in Florida where he where
he lives now to try and prosecute him so
the concept of the potential universal
jurisdiction may may have come to the
United States with this case we'll have
to see how it turns out but I think
there's no doubt that that in terms of
the concept of the globalisation of
justice the Pinochet precedent has
certainly spurred on other countries to
try this tactic as often as they can and
I think we'll be seeing more of those
types of prosecutions certainly
dictators former dictators like Pinochet
are much more hesitant to leave their
their home bases their sanctuaries of
power and travel abroad at this point
I thank you for your huge effort
educational efforts just a point about
there was a document dot doc is injure
which covers Chile I'm not sure have you
seen it the trials of Henry Kissinger is
that the one you're referring to yeah
it's a documentary uh-huh have you seen
that yeah I'm in that movie and I've
seen it a second minor point is the name
Pinochet sounds French is that right is
that his background is the French and
what is the what is the background of
does anybody know he has his
grandmother's from Brittany is it uh-huh
I see well that's the answer to that
question his grandmother's from Brittany
in last Friday's Wall Street Journal a
writer argued that Pinochet really saved
Chile from becoming a totalitarian state
and that French Secret Service we're
training thousands of people from around
the world revolutionaries too presumably
to help it make to help it become a
totalitarian state apart from the fact
that the wall street journal is a high
ultra conservative newspaper and that
the writer doesn't express any concern
for the thousands that were killed under
Pinochet is there any validity to the
claim that you know this was going to
turn into another I don't know China I
guess or at this point US policymakers
and and and in conservative observers of
politics such as the person who wrote
that that that article always made
assumptions about about socialists
Marxists etc ine was a Marxist but he
was never Marxist Leninist he was never
a Stalinist he had a long very venerable
and prestigious history in Chile in
politics he'd run for president three
times before he actually won in 1970 he
came very close to winning 1958 which
would have totally changed that
history of Latin America if he had been
elected at that point and become the
first freely elected Marxist leader then
rather than Fidel Castro becoming that
the model of revolution in Latin America
a year a year later and and that was
something that astute CIA analysts also
understood that Chile represent a very
different model from from from Fidel
Castro almost the antithesis of Castro's
model Kissinger himself laid it out how
I end a was going to behave he
considered it a ruse but it wasn't IND
who closed down the Free Press
it wasn't IND who invaded the
universities it wasn't IND who closed
down Congress and banned political
parties and it wasn't IND who created a
secret police force and to to to wield
repression to implement a vast
repressive policy it was it was Pinochet
and all the people that argued as the
writer in the Wall Street Journal did
never said absolutely anything about
that there was nothing that I think
certainly a yen date was pressing for
substantive change in Chile more than he
had the popular support to to implement
he also had on his left outside of his
coalition leftist forces who were Pro
Cuba some of them had been to Cuba some
of them were working with Cubans who
wanted to press along his acceleration
is the momentum of change in Chile and
those forces were just as problematic
for I end day as any of his aides will
tell you as as the right-wing forces
he didn't control them he it was very
difficult to to suppress them although
anybody was in Chile at the time knows
that that many of their protests and
land seizures were were suppressed were
reversed etc but they created extreme
problems for him as well was there any
possibility that yeni would have created
a totalitarian system I don't think the
Chilean system from what I know of it
would have actually permitted that at no
point would he ever have been able to
take over the military which at all
points have had remained constitutional
could have assured that the
constitutional transactions of the
future of Chile it wasn't any force that
would juxtapose or you know counter the
force of the military so when you look
at the calculations that Kissinger and
Nixon made I don't think any of them
were based in in the actual facts of the
Chilean past or or the Chilean future
the argument I'll just return to it that
Kissinger and Nixon made was that their
efforts in Chile were to preserve
democracy there but the extraordinary
fact is that once all of those bastions
of democracy that they had said they
were supporting were essentially
repressed by Pinochet there was not a
single effort to support them I have in
my um I have in the book a very
interesting story of the debate inside
the US government of continuing to
covertly support the Christian
Democratic Party in the year following
the coup and there was a series of
arguments that were made this ambassador
Davis and then his successor ambassador
popper wanted to support the Christian
Democrats because they hoped that
support for them would lead them to
support the hanta the CIA ironically
this was most most extraordinary the CIA
wanted that Christian to support the
Christian Democrats in the aftermath of
the coup because they felt that there
would eventually be a return to the
democratic process in Chile and they
wanted the Christian Democrats to be the
strongest to be stronger than the
leftist parties which were being
repressed at that point but what might
reemerge and US officials around
Kissinger a few of them wanted to
support the Christian Democrats because
they realized how hypocritical it would
be if they suddenly cut off aid to the
one main symbol of democracy in Chile
but Kissinger and his aides decided that
they did not want to offend
P noche by continuing to support a
political party that he had banned and
so they authorized one miniscule final
payment of $50,000 to the Christian
Democratic Party and aid was cut off I
have one of the descent memos reprinted
in the book which is well worth reading
where a mid-level State Department
official says you know I would like to
see a time when the United States was on
the right side of history in Latin
America and supporting a symbol of
democracy in Chile against a government
as he wrote that can be documented to be
fistic tyrannical militaristic and
murderous is something we should do this
is not Peter Kornbluth speaking this is
one of kissinger's aides in the State
Department writing to oppose the
decision to cut off covert support for
the Christian Democratic Party sir thank
you for what you wrote and what you said
tonight let me say briefly that if
anything American foreign policy in
Latin America has not only been right
has been extremely right dangerously
right
in fact just as vice president Ford when
he became president had the great
courage to pardoned Richard Nixon I
think he sinned for a serious omission
of not awarding Richard up not awarding
Kissinger the John Foster Dulles medal
for patriotism and patriotic
anti-communism now leaving black humor
aside about 20 years ago there was a
very touching movie that was made I
believe in Hollywood called missing
about that American person journalist I
believe that was caught and executed and
the efforts of his widow to find out the
action that movie without perhaps than
all the you know backing of all these
declassified documents I think already
laid out very clearly what was the the
nature of the
government and sort of served as a
serious indictment against the u.s.
foreign policy did you think that he
played such a role the movie missing was
a pivotal event as a Hollywood product
and as a movie that really I think
brought Chile and the whole issue of
u.s. foreign policy and Chile to to to
public attention in a huge way we year
ago my son and I went to a major event
celebrating the 20th anniversary of the
movie in New York City
the director Constantine costa-gavras
was there joyce Horman was there the
real widow of Charles Horman and [ __ ]
Spacek who played her in the movie was
also there and it was a movie that I
suggest everybody see anybody who I'm
sure most everybody seen how many people
seen missing how many people haven't
seen missing very few you haven't seen
the movie but it's a certainly as a
movie worth seeing and I think it had it
had a huge huge impact on us as it's
showing that the power of a forceful
Hollywood movie with with with with
great reach Peters you're well aware
soon after the coup congressman Don
Fraser chaired the subcommittee House
Internet Relations Committee had a
series of hearings on Chile co-chaired
with Danny Facel senator Kennedy was
active on the Senate side of course Tom
Harkin is a junior House member made a
trip to Chile to what extent to these
things make any difference or were they
simply a nuisance to the Kissinger or
were they or were they helpful to the
such as the lower-level
mid-level official you mentioned earlier
did they have some impact on on working
what what do you think was the
difference or impact
1 anybody interested in human rights
needs to study the case of Chile the
human rights movement as we know it
today grew up around the Chilean issue
the laws that were passed in the offices
that were just mentioned also with
Senator Kennedy in the Senate and in the
house bonkers and Purcell and and Harkin
and George Miller and Toby Moffett
really where you can call them the
Pinochet Kissinger laws because they
were a response from Congress to to to
Kissinger's desire to aid Pinochet
despite his despite his egregious human
rights violations and what you can see
in the documents is how this debate and
how growing congressional pressure
infiltrated the State Department and
caused Henry Kissinger great upset we
have the Declassified transcripts of
many of his meetings which were
dominated by him yelling at his aides
not to let Ted Kennedy and Congressman
bonkers get away with be a passing
legislation that would restrict
Kissinger's ability to give military
support and economic support to Pinochet
and to other military dictators and this
comes to a head in in meetings in late
1974 and mid 1975 and Kissinger
basically advances three arguments that
are very important with it with his
aides we shouldn't let this happen
because Pinochet is no worse than I yen
day was no worse than any other
government down there he kind of peppers
his aides with this question you know is
it worse than any other Latin American
countries and his deputy has to tell him
yes
and then his second argument is
basically that if we don't give this aid
to Pinochet he's going to fall he's
going to collapse and this is I think
for me the most extraordinary argument
you know Kissinger really stepped up and
said I don't want to stop this
government to collapse and I don't want
to cut off aid to it and I don't want
there to be a resurgence of the
political forces that it overthrew and
he and he makes this argument again and
again and again and finally his final
argument was that of course if the
Congress got away with restricting aid
to Pinochet it would get away with
restricting aid to all all sorts of
other countries what's next he said to
his aides Taiwan South Korea you know if
we give them an inch they'll take a mile
that kind of that kind of argument and
finally and I just I just have to share
this with you I just have to share this
with you he says he says this is insane
says to you know this is congressional
efforts to restrict my ability to give
aid to Pinochet is insane and is deputy
assistant secretary for Latin America
says it is insane but mr. secretary it
does reflect an extraordinarily strong
feeling amongst the Congress as you will
know you can go to the man on it now if
you want to and I protect predict you
will have a hell of a fight on your
hands there are a lot of Democrats on
the hill this coming session who want to
go to the mat on the issue of human
rights and want to make a fight about it
it is very hard to make a national
interest argument on Chile the human
rights issue has caught the imagination
up on the hill as you well know mr.
secretary and amongst the American
people my diagnosis is the reason they
have stuck to it they've stuck it to the
department in this case is that they
don't think we are sincere on human
rights and that was William Rogers
assistant secretary for Latin America
speaking to to Kissinger and them in a
meeting in late 1974 I think it gives
you a sense from the inside of the
impact that the work that a number of
people even in this room including
yourself we're doing at the time
and how it was and how it was bringing
pressure on on Henry Kissinger his
policies towards Chile yes right here I
want to say as a Chilean looking back
you know the Chilean government of a yen
day was always caught in the struggle in
the internal struggle and beside that
with the foreign policy of the United
States again the first thing that he did
in his government was to nationalize the
copper mine
I was raw material I was poor as he used
to say the budget of the Chilean people
the salary of our workers then he touch
a very sensitive point you know for the
American interest besides that the
internal problems you know was within
the parties always the Christian
democracy was trying to make a parallel
between the leftist coalition with the
Cuban Revolution and I June as an agenda
just to say always this is a revolution
meaning that is going to be a big change
but in Liberty and he really committed
himself a bit when was demanded by our
Congress that never could be you know
violated our Constitution the result of
all this sad you know situation the
involvement of the CIA the foreign
American foreign policy and so you know
is that up to now we have not recovered
our democracy we don't have a full
democracy in Chile because still we are
ruined well the constitution of Pinochet
that he designated some senators and we
we are struggling for that we don't have
majority when I say we don't have you
know they elected it doesn't matter a
right or left but Pinochet Constitution
is the one that is ruling Chile up to
now and that is the reason that mr.
Panucci that was declare insane you know
he socialized I met him in a cafe in
Santiago Chile
one months ago very happy day insane you
see I want to say only that if I'm
emotional with me
well it wasn't it wasn't a question it
wasn't a question but it was a very
important comment go ahead I'm really
humbled to follow such eloquence with
two fairly mundane questions but the
first one the in the trials of Henry
Kissinger he speaks the the
documentarian speaks about the case of
Renee Snyder's family against Kissinger
on the morning of September 11th 2001
getting completely you know obviously
over overturned by all that else went on
that day what is the current status of
that case and then my second question is
just you know listening to you tonight
and these documents III walk away here
feeling such such pessimism such sadness
about Halil we've learned from this
particularly in the current
circumstances that we face with our our
senior officials do you have any more
optimism and hope about this than I am
left with tonight not really
chargeable on the case of Rene Schneider
is is one that was investigated by the
Senate committee in 1975 there were a
number of documents it turns out that
was were not shown to that committee and
I've been able to read them and use them
and in revisiting that case again I
actually gave the first chapter of the
book several years ago to 60 minutes and
they just that they found out that the
family of Rene Schneider was going to
sue Henry Kissinger and Richard Helms
the CIA director for wrongful death in a
US Court this was again in the aftermath
of the impact of Pino chaise arrest and
the possibility that a crime committed
there and Chile could perhaps be
prosecuted here at least in in a under
to submit is not a not a criminal case
but a civil case and 60 minutes did air
on Sunday night September 9th 2001 a
piece that all about the Schneider case
no the new documents and
and the whole issue of Kissinger's
potential or alleged responsibility in
in this episode the case was then filed
in u.s. court the next day on September
10th and on the morning of September
11th the Washington Post ran a very long
story but of course by the afternoon of
September 11th dr. Kissinger was on
television and actually talking about
how the Senate investigation into
alleged assassinations of foreign
leaders in the mid-1970s had restricted
the CIA from being able to assassinate
people like Osama bin Laden and that
that really was the villain here that
Congress had somehow undermine our
ability to to to carry out executive
action against Osama bin Laden so he
become you know an advocate of
assassination of course he was mistaken
the Clinton administration had been
trying for three years to assassinate
sama bin Laden the CIA had carte blanche
to to get him whenever it could and it
just hadn't been able to the
opportunities he had that the agency had
had were too narrow too small involved
too many civilian casualties and they
had not been able to to carry out this
this mission certainly I think Chile
does resonate today and I haven't welled
as much as I could have done on the
misrepresentation of this policy but
honesty in government became a big issue
in the aftermath of the Chilean case US
officials had repeatedly testified to
Congress that our policy in Chile was to
have the type of relations with a yen
day that he wanted to have with us and
we have the declassified documents which
shows that that is absolutely false
dr. Kissinger testified before the
Senate on in September of 1974 he was
asked about Chile about the u.s. role in
the coup and he said it was not our
policy to subvert or to stabilize the I
end a government and we have the
declassified documents now we're meeting
after meeting after meeting he pushes
and authorizes and directs exactly that
that policy and those
documents are in the book for for
anybody to see and so I think that is
that is an issue again chile was a very
different case than the types of cases
were confronting today it was a
democratically elected government that
had never repressed anybody that had
never threatened the United States with
violence did not have weapons of mass
destruction was not a terrorist regime
etc this was about covert intervention
not about overt intervention but some of
the same issues that have been debated
over the last year were internally at
least debated as this policy unfolded in
in in Chile and then certainly in the
aftermath of the coup Chile became the
catalyst for the first national debate
over the propriety of covert operations
and the first national debate over
institutionalizing human rights as a
criteria of our foreign policy we are
now into a debate over humanitarian
intervention but there was obviously a
major issue about a major difference
clearly there is a major difference
between between overthrowing a tyrant
and installing one and so there's there
are grave differences but but in the
broad themes Chile does offer a lot of
lessons and most of them don't seem to
be to be being learned right at this
moment I Peter my question follows on
from that question in your comments
somebody once said I think that what we
learn from the close study of history is
that we don't learn from history and in
fact so much of what went wrong in a
fundamental sense with the US policy and
manipulation in Chile has been hidden
except over time with you and others so
courageously and skillfully drawing it
forth painfully drawing it forth and a
lot of it's still in the shadows and now
we have a government that's behaving in
that fashion at least as with at least
as much effect and malign intent as
Nixon and Kissinger ever did I was going
to ask what you
a sense of hopefulness about that was
but you sort of answered that maybe the
thing to ask is the slender kind of
Avenue toward a truthful understanding
that's the only platform in which better
and more honest policies can be fought
for is to know as much of what went on
as possible and therefore National
Security archives and the case study of
the Chilean papers gives us one example
of that how are you and the endeavor to
have that kind of access that kind of
release of public documents and
therefore some glimmer of the truth how
is that faring under george w bush
currently an administration that is so
steeped in secrecy and doing it behind
closed doors I mean how do you see the
future of the generic effort to get
public revelation of the public's
business a difficult and hard road under
the the justification of fighting
terrorism secrecy has been significantly
expanded in our government circles and
in almost every realm you'd be
interested to know that there are
documents that have been Declassified
and on the shelves of the National
Archives for years that have now been
reclassified under review and are being
censored even though they've been
sitting on the shelves for for many
years because of a change in criteria
over what should be open to the public
and what shouldn't be open to the public
and obviously in the difficult situation
that we're in the arguments for further
secrecy are being made being
institutionalized and being implemented
it's going to be harder to get
presidential papers in the future it's
going to be harder to use the Freedom of
Information Act I think that you'll
still be able to get documents on
foreign policy episodes going back to
the 70s but more recent issues are going
to be very difficult
where will you will rimi tear in 30
years on the anniversary of the war of
Iraq to
study whatever declassified documents we
are possibly able to get by that time
and I can guarantee you even if we do
that we won't have all the documents 30
years from now because many of them will
still be secret 30 years from now I I
believe it was the famous philosopher
that once said you know sunlight is the
best disinfectant and that is
particularly true when it comes to
transparency in government there's no
doubt that the world has changed there's
no doubt that US policies have to be
different given what happened to us two
years ago but to use secrecy and expand
secrecy under the guise of fighting
terrorism is in the end going to be a
formula for the types of activities that
we've seen in the past that as Colin
Powell put it weren't proud moments for
our country I'm going to stop you've
been so wonderful to sit here I
appreciate it
I'm going to sit here and sign a few
books if anybody wants their book signed
but thank you so very much for coming
the Pinto jet file a declassified
dossier on atrocity and accountability
is published by the new press on the web
at new press com